(upbeat music)
- Your necklace looks
really pretty on you.
- Oh, thank you.
- No problem.
- Amy, she's totally straight.
- Uh no, she can totally be gay.
- Those nails, that
sweater, she's straight.
- Fuck you, she can still be gay.
- For the record, I'm straight.
(uptempo music)
- [Voiceover] How do
you meet anyone anymore?
Straight girls go to gay bars.
Speed dating is weird.
Are you okay?
- I'm sorry, I just, I just got out of a
really long-term relationship.
- Oh.
- Like yesterday.
It's like really fresh (squeals).
- Online dating is a bust.
- I love adventure
and me and my boyfriend are
looking for an adventurous girl
to join us.
- I've never been with a woman before.
- Hi!
- I'm in an open marriage
and we're looking for another woman.
(slow uplifting music)
- [Voiceover] Amy?
(sparkles)
- Sorry, I'm Amy.
- So am I.
(chuckles)
(uplifting music)
- [Voiceover] You ever just meet someone
and feel an immediate connection?
Someone that you feel like
you know everything about
just by looking into their eyes?
(uplifting music)
I know we only met two hours ago,
but I really think you're the one
I'm meant to be with.
(phone rings)
- Sorry, it's my boyfriend.
(record scratches)
- Your what?
- Actually, we're looking for
a fun girl for a threesome.
Would you possibly--
- God, damn it!
- So is that a no?
(uplifting music)
- [Voiceover] He can just watch.
(whimsical pop music)
- Hi!
- Oh, hey guys!
- Sarah!
- Huh?
- Over here.
- We made a series.
- It's coming on November 18th.
- Please watch it.
- Get it here.
- There.
- Over here.
- Over there. You got it.
I think they got it.
Okay, I'm out.
Okay, bye!
- It'll be released 2015, November.
- [Voiceover] Quinta!
- Okay.